oh my god no thank you
today we're gonna be guessing how much
it costs to have kids in the US my
parents always talk about how it's very
expensive I think I want to have at
least two I like my first one yeah I
would say like 26 or 27 I don't have any
recent plans all right these questions
yes true or false the main cost of
raising a child including housing food
transportation healthcare education
clothing and other miscellaneous
expenses yeah I think that covers most
of it I think that's true yeah but isn't
that like everything that was true true
or false
a nursery set typically cost around five
hundred dollars including a crib
changing table rocker and dresser I
think it might be more small ribs expand
address it yeah maybe in a dresser yeah
maybe the dresser
yeah okay the dresser took it over
that's crazy
true or false according to the national
diaper bank network the cost of diapers
range between seventy to eighty dollars
per month or nine hundred per year how
much comes in a box
I don't think diapers are that expensive
I've never bought diapers before but
sounds true yes true or false
new parents may lose the equivalent of
20 nights of sleep within the first 12
months of a child's life okay I thought
it took more than 29 12 months that has
to mean it has to be more whether it's a
quiet baby
I think it's wrong I heard I was a quiet
baby I'm gonna support myself
[Laughter]
adoption can range from 15,000 to 40,000
in the US and international adoptions
can cost as much as 10,000 I didn't
realize it you paid that much I didn't
wait I don't know you paid for adoptions
that's like buying a kid feel like it's
the opposite
like adoption in the u.s. is probably
cheaper
oh my god sure Falls in vitro
fertilization can cost up to $40,000 per
round and many people may need multiple
rounds of IVF to conceive sure yeah
that's true I've had like relatives
who've done interview and I just know
it's really expensive that was true
really yeah you sound confident and I'm
pretty confident with that one
I'm gangrel more affordable so true or
false the USDA says that house and
accounts for 26 to 33 percent of the
total cost of raising a child this takes
up the largest percent of the total cost
of child rearing this comes from
averaging the cost of an additional
bedroom
I feel like 26 to 33 is like a realistic
allowed house like 30 or should be like
30 percent of your income as of 2017 the
Department of Agriculture reported that
the estimated average cost of raising a
child from birth to age 17 for a
middle-income family with two children
is more than one hundred and seventy
thousand dollars
generally I think it's a little less cuz
it's until seventeen so you're not like
including college costs that's more than
like us like a supercar I'd like to
think that I'm worth more than a
supercar
[Laughter]
no thank you
this is the last one food costs make up
around 18% of the cost of raising a
child for middle-income families with
two children it says two children does
that okay how's that make a difference I
think it's more like yes I kind of get
why my parents always complain about me
any money now I'm not ready
see nice of
[Music]